little nasdaq's is single and wants it
to stay that way i'm feeling like i'm on
cloud like 179
000 million
google
the 22 year old musician opens up in the
wall street journal magazine's november
innovators issue about being happy with
his status as a newly single man just
celebrate and live in this moment about
right now right now is what matters lil
nas first revealed he was dating someone
in august telling variety that the
mystery person may be the one shortly
after he shared in v-man magazine that
he and his then partner met in may
calling their relationship quote natural
and effortless then in october during an
interview with siriusxm's hits one he
revealed the person in question was his
that's what i want music video co-star
yai ariza but they had called it quits
we were dating uh
and we're still in very good terms you
know we may date again i'm sure i love
him he's he's amazing i wanted to like
just kind of focus on my music
right now but now lil nas is doubling
down on his single status saying he's
not ready to date again but the singer
says he has maintained a positive
relationship with all of his exes so
much so that they attended the release
party of his debut album montero which
features songs about many of them little
nas says only one of his former loves
took offense at the portrayal of their
relationship in the grammy winner's
music and get this
he also revealed that while he was
working on the album he tried
psychedelic mushrooms for the first time
something he says allowed him to push
past lots of lingering feelings of
self-consciousness quote i was able to
open up a lot i was able to write actual
stories about my life and put it into my
music i actually did that for the first
time now lil na says he's focused on his
music career and living in the moment
something he opened up to et about back
in september after winning video of the
year at the mtv vmas what are you gonna
do tonight to celebrate bed i'm gonna
have a great time with my brothers and
and my friends
and you know just celebrate and live in
this moment about right now right now is
what matters
yes oh my god i'm so thankful i'm so
thankful and while he's hyper focused on
work he still finds time for fun for
halloween lil knows dressed up as the
harry potter dark lord voldemort from
this day forth
you put your
faith in me
and seth powers from ned's declassified
school survival guide
[Music]
and to sum up life right now little
nausea told wall street journal quote
i'm at the best place i've ever been in
life but i always feel like i'm one step
away from where i want to be at the end
of the day i want to exist i want to
have fun i want to cause chaos sometimes
i want a long legendary fun life